[Music]
Benefit Cosmetics is one of the top
beauty brands for eyebrow products it's
precisely my brow pencil is one of its
best selling products on average it
sells one brow pencil every two seconds
talked about popular to learn a bit more
about what makes this brow pencil such a
favorite we got a look behind the scenes
of how it's made at benefits Tokyo
Factory the process begins with a
variety of pigments white black yellow
and red pigments go into the pencil
those pigments are combined with
ingredients such as stearic acid which
helps to thicken the mixture and prevent
the pencil from smearing on your brow
from their wax and oils are added to
bind all the ingredients together and if
it's brow pencil requires a variety of
waxes and oils including fruit wax
beeswax and coconut oil once everything
is combined the mixture is poured into a
large rolling machine the machine triple
rolls the formula turning it into the
consistency of pencil shavings the loose
mixture is then compressed into a log
shape which will become the pencils
quarter more than 20,000 pieces of
pencil core will come from this
compressed mixture a machine cuts it
ultra fine making each chord exactly the
same
once the pencils are made there are two
tests each one has to go through before
it gets packaged and shipped the shade
test and the durability test which are
two of the most important aspects of
what makes benefits brow pencils so
unique so what makes C precisely my brow
pencil different from any other brow
pencil I would say the shade range we
suit every hair color every skin tone
the other thing I love about it is that
it is a very durable pencil for as tiny
as it is you can put quite a bit of
pressure and that thing won't break the
shade test make sure each pencil is the
exact color it's supposed to be to do
this the pen
are meticulously swatched and compared
benefits pencils also go through a
durability test the core is tested to
make sure it can endure up to 25 times
its own weight without breaking next the
pencils are hand filled with support
each pencil is x-rayed to make sure its
quality and its packaging are perfect
the precisely my brow pencils are then
hand packed and sent to stores in over
55 countries all over the world
[Music]
you